American assassin it wasn't boring it
wasn't cliche the only bad part was
Dylan O'Brien's performance transfer was
last night it did things that are
different than the other Transformers
films it's exciting and entertaining
there's great character in it The Dark
Tower really took its time built its
world well Matthew McConaughey didn't
look weird in it it doesn't sacrifice
good storytelling for a good action it
does it does the opposite
the mummy was cool it introduces the
mummy that's why we showed up for it so
it really knew its audience and knew
that it needed a good mummy it doesn't
make it a Tom Cruise vehicle like you
thought it would be the last half is way
better than the first half Leatherface
was finally the reboot that Texas
Chainsaw Massacre movies needed now if
you take the opposite opinion and then
you have my top 5 worst movie list BAM
let's go to the best movies
I reject nation I'm getting out my
favorite movies of 2017 list out just on
time nope that's a lie it is like six or
seven days late depending on when this
video is coming out I'm gonna give you
guys a heads up most people do a top 10
list I've seen a lot of movies this year
a lot so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
rank my favorite 15 movies I'm a spit
fall through them super quick some of
them we haven't done reviews on but most
of them there are full-length reviews
for them on YouTube before I hop into
this list I want to say thank you to
everyone who's been becoming a part of
our patreon our patreon page is really
growing a lot right now it's become like
a more personal free-flowing YouTube
channel do like a weekly Q&A and we have
a lot of music video reactions on there
a lot of exclusive reactions and just a
lot of special videos over there I'm
having such a blast thank you to
everyone who's really been becoming a
part of the patron eject nation love for
you to join - I haven't actually seen
anyone elses top movie list at all no
not a single person yet because I didn't
want anyone to influence mine alright so
number 15 for me would have to be three
billboards outside a bank misery
I actually just caught this movie this
week and I was like I have to throw it
on my list I would have to save Frances
McDorman is probably my favorite
performance of the entire year she's so
good in it she kind of reminds me of
every woman I've ever
that's not true it's a really effective
story and a great character study of all
these people dealing with a very
specific controversial event so it's a
pretty edgy ass film and it really goes
all out
the reason it's number 15 is because I'm
one of the people who fell under the
category who didn't fully agree with how
the movie ended this movie had an ending
that was very much debated I even had to
go look up to see exactly what the
director intended with the ending of the
film and even though I read what the
director had to say I was still like uh
yeah I I don't actually agree with how
this film concludes he kind of left me
hanging a little bit I was a little
surprised that it ended where it did I
could have used another half-hour you
know the film's already two hours but
for everything that we got even the
final scene of the movie it's perfectly
acted the script is awesome it's just
the ending and the fact that it's just a
really freaking depressing yeah it's so
depressing I saw monsters ball while I
was on vacation during Christmas and
that's one of those movies that's super
depressing it just keeps getting more
depressing and it this is one of those
films too but I guess there's a tiny
shred of hope at the end of the tunnel
number fourteen is a great transition
from three billboards I'm talking about
none other than Thor Ragnarok Thor
Ragnarok talked about plenty on this
channel it's to me one of the best MCU
films just because it's number fourteen
on my list doesn't make it like oh one
of the films I like the least this is my
favorite films of 2017 thro Ragnarok was
and completely entertaining Chris
Hemsworth kills it in this movie all the
characters are great I've talked about
this movie so much it was on the rank in
the comic book movies list just know
it's one of my favorite MCU films hands
down number thirteen for me would have
to be Blade Runner 2049 number thirteen
is probably not where it should actually
be at on this list I think the reason
why it's number thirteen is because of
my specific viewing experience like an
idiot youtuber I can sometimes be I did
a live stream and said that I was on my
way to see Blade Runner 2049 and I
figured I was going to opening day so
you know no one's gonna ruin it for me
and it's a live stream but I was 180,000
percent wrong I got the major plot
points spoiled for me during that live
stream and then I watched it ten minutes
and it really had an effect on me like I
knew it's more about the journey and all
those things there's lumber to take and
just these plot to us it was still
really put in the forefront of my mind
when I was watching it before my
observant analytical side and there were
plenty of scenes it still had me gripped
and Ryan Gosling of course I still
really loved the film I think it's way
better than the first one I'm not almost
in one of those people who doesn't
really care for the first Blade Runner
this one though I think is amazing it
sucks that it bombed but it's also not a
surprise me the first one's a flop and
then known rizona like oh hey now I'm
putting this movie at number 12 as I put
this at number 12 I was thinking I
wonder if I'm gonna get a lot of crap
for not making this part of the top 10
at least that is baby driver baby driver
to me is still one of my favorite films
of the year I thoroughly enjoyed the
hell out of this movie it's super
entertaining the editing is great and
even though I consider it probably my
second favorite Edgar Wright film there
was something there that I can't quite
pinpoint that didn't emotionally get me
enough and not that it needs to do that
if you watched our review for the film
you'll see how I truly feel about the
film and it's also been some time since
I've seen it I mean you see a lot of
movies throughout the year but I do
remember this being easily one of the
most entertaining films I've seen all
year and one of the most impressive
edited films and choreographed films
I've seen all year as well alright
number eleven oh boy I can't wait to get
crap for this one mother here I put a
mother at number 11 on my list it was a
movie that frustrated that out of me it
was a movie that got me thinking oh it
was chaotic in the theater I remember
when the movie was done I went what the
[ __ ] was that and people started
laughing but it was also a movie that
just had me thinking for days I I
thought about this movie for a while and
the more I thought about it the more I
liked it I liked how ballsy it is I like
how it really just goes all out and the
performances are good and it does
different things that you just wouldn't
see in a typical Hollywood movie these
days and even though the marketing is
very misleading
the film itself is something to absorb
and after I ruminate it all for
while ruminated rarely use that word
after our Ruben I didn't for a while I
realized you know what I love the [ __ ]
out of this movie
alright entering the top ten zone here
number 10 for me would have to be none
other than the February's get out
actually got quite a few horror movies
on here and some people might consider
mother or horror movie get out Jordan
peels directorial debut was quite an
impactful hit this one it was an amazing
film the performance by Daniel kahlúa is
amazing man that hypnosis seemed oh he's
crying everything that was a great great
a scene the revelations that were going
in the way this plot unfolds it is one
of those like horror thrillers that you
could watch on repeat viewings and then
still go man this is a really clever
film you can get more from it each time
you watch it arguably it should be way
higher on my list but right now it just
sits at number 10 my feelings tend to
fluctuate number 9 for me is split split
was such a delightful surprise you know
M night Shyamalan making his comeback
with a visit sort of that was like an
introduction it was come back and split
was his official comeback this film was
an intense ride I love a good mystery
building plot James McAvoy in this film
it's just so amazing him alone is the
reason to watch this movie I feel like
even if you don't like this movie
there's no denying James McAvoy kills it
in this film it's came out in January so
as a minor spoiler but it did something
that no one was expecting but it gets
you excited for a crossover movie that
was announced within the movie even
though I didn't really love that scene
specifically the concept and the idea
and the announcement in it of itself I'm
looking forward to infinity war like
like crazy next year I really am if
there's a trailer I can't wait to see
it's definitely the glass trailer and
this movie man it gets you pumped for
that after seeing a breakable and split
and it gets you pumped number 7 on my
list is a low-budget indie horror comedy
that I don't know how many people saw I
don't think that maybe feels like it's
my it's my edgy number one it's my would
to make me stand down that would be this
movie called tragedy girls I
saw the trailer for this movie loved it
and then I ended up watching the movie I
love this film if you guys haven't seen
tragedy girls it is one fantastic comedy
horror film it's a movie that takes it
from the perspective of serial killers
in high school it really rides this dark
tone that never loses the comedy beats
and really commits to its murderous
aspects it gets violent it gets dark it
gets cynical but it has such a weird
heart about it and I love a movie with
main characters where you're so Pack and
forth on whether or not you should love
them or hate them and that works in
great effect for this movie performances
all around our great seriously if you
haven't seen tragedy girls I highly
recommend watching this film because
then it of being one of my favorite
movies of the year alright so number
seven for me Star Wars the last Jetta
Star Wars the last Jedi is a movie I
have talked way too much about on this
channel I know it's an audience divisive
film with the Star Wars fans but I have
to steal Jon's line I think he put it
best lose your line again John it does
great film things for it makes good film
choices of a bad Star Wars toy PSA's
quote me on it you guys know I feel
about it it's my second favorite Star
Wars movie of all time
BAM get mad the shape of water I just
caught this movie the other day did a
full review for it on patreon long as
Tom the shape of water is a beautiful
romantic film that manages to weave so
many different elements so many
different plots within this world of the
1960s and it's all comes to great
resolution by the end there's no plot
left hanging the performances by Michael
Shannon and Sally Hawkins Richard
Jenkins Octavia Spencer and the creature
who's you know obviously paying tribute
to the Creature from the Black Lagoon
their romance was so believable in Sally
Hawkins gives one of the best
performances of the year Sally Hawkins
has one of those body language roles in
here and she moved me to tears like at
least a couple times in this
and the direction the cinematography the
music everything about it is Guillermo
de Toro
at its best I know waiting for del Toro
to do another film in pure del Toro
fashion and this is it another movie I
finally caught this week the big sick
the big sick is the true story based on
Kumail Nanjiani his real-life story of
how he met his wife of course there's
things that are tweaked for movie
preferences it's a story of a Pakistani
man who's been raised in America and
he's become very American he falls in
love with a white girl but because his
family wants him to marry a Pakistani
woman creates conflict with him and his
girl and his girl his girl ends up
landing into a medically induced coma
and it's his awkward tale about him
having to hang out with his girl's
parents who don't really care for him
it's just really just human tale it's
one of the more simple movies of this
whole list but it's incredibly funny
incredibly heart touching I kind of
compare it to being a more realistic
version of something like My Big Fat
Greek Wedding because it has those
family touching vibes about sick and
true to your ethnic roots at the same
time though you know it has that Judd
Apatow with a male Nanjiani r-rated
style of humor the performances are so
sincere and so authentic and while
there's some whimsical stuff to be had
it also has a realistic approach to it
as well it's one of the more mature
romantic comedies I fell in love with
this movie and it's that movie that made
me feel really good when it was done
number four for me was the movie that I
was kind of surprised became one of my
top five favorite movies of the year but
once I was done watching it I was like
yep definitely is and that is Coco Coco
is a beautifully animated film about so
many family themes and messages and
values and about following your heart
and pursuing your passion and knowing
what's important in your life
it is easily one of Pixar's best movies
we did a top 5 picks our list recently
and I listed Coco pretty high up there
and the music in this movie is great I
think this movie made me tear up the
most I think when I look at my top 5 I
think they all made me cry at some point
and this movie had me tear up a lot I
was so moved by it and it's a delightful
family film it's the definition of a
great
we film one that kids will love and one
that adults will probably love in some
ways even more number three is a comedy
or like a dramedy that I knew I would
like I just knew I was gonna like it I
wasn't expecting to love the [ __ ] out of
this movie it is a movie that
surprisingly inspired me it's a movie
about the worst movie of all time yet
they make what is one of the best movies
of the year and that is the disaster
artist the disaster artist is based on
the true story of the making of the room
and James Franco man he pills it in this
movie he is so good it was interesting
to see a guy having to portray a dude
who's known to get one of the worst
performances in film history and make a
great sincere performance out of it it's
a movie that's more than just watching a
disaster take place at the end of the
day it's a movie about following your
dreams and following your heart and you
never know what might become of that you
never know what what might be special
that comes from it I remember watching
the room and feeling like there's
something kind of special about this
movie because you feel good when you
watch the room you know if it's terrible
you feel good this movie ends in a way
where you see this specialty of the room
and beyond that it's just a delightful
journey of best friends and and I'm
following your ambitions it's amazing
this might get confusing because we did
a ranking of the top comic book movies
of 2017 I put this as my number one for
this list I was coming at it a little
bit different I was thinking of like
what are the best films look as I said
like this is arguably the second best
konbu film it's my favorite comic book
film that year in terms of just film I
would make it number two and that is
Wonder Woman I've talked plenty about
this it's number two okay I'm just
saying that it's beautiful it's awesome
films is everything I pretty much wanted
a movie there you go
number ones Logan talk point about it
too no need to go into all the details
right it's epic it's great send-off for
Hugh Jackman it's it's like my kind of
movie in terms of its Western slow bill
vibe of great violence and great
character that's badass
cool coolest movie of 2017 alright guys
well instead of asking you the question
that ever
asking I'm sure what's her favorite
movie of twenties I'll ask you guys what
do you think will be your favorite movie
of 2018 or your favorites have you
already sold yourself but this will be
your favorite even though you haven't
seen it you guys can subscribe to the
reel rejects please click that
notification Bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is up and please
check out our patreon become a patron
oject today it's like a second youtube
channel
[Music]